I was always kind of dreaming in this
game since I've been a kid you know um
in a really real way
I didn't think I'll make that game I
just thought wouldn't it be cool if
there was a game where and I think
everyone has had that I think I heard
somebody saying it's like a pitch from a
child basically riches like you know
there'll be a universe and you can go
everywhere and you can have a ship and
you can shoot lasers and you know all
that kind of thing is like the most
childish idea for a game in the world
and it was really fueled by sapphires as
I had always experienced it which was
was books books that I'd grown up with
like actual science fiction we always
knew that we wanted to make no man's sky
at the time that was called project
skyscraper a big ambitious name for it
we always knew the type of game we want
you to make and we'd known it before we
even started hello games and we had
talked about it at that point and we
knew that Joe danger was going to be
stepping stone towards that the
Challenger Series which is like four
games nyan and like turn on console and
two on mobile
they were like a complete labor of love
you know like I love those games still a
lot of people did and they were way more
successful than we thought they would be
or have any right to be because we were
so terrible at everything apart from
making games
it really kind of properly started a
year and a half ago it's not quite a
year and a half ago a year and five
months or something and that was when
four of us slightly different forward to
to the fourth and fan of the company
just found a small room within that
large office and we actually just like
literally locked the door and had a
separate entrance and stuff like that
and squirreled ourselves away and we
started working on prototype for no
man's sky and we actually didn't show
the rest of the team because we just
wanted almost the pressure and the
isolation almost like it was a startup
within this small studio that had to
prove themselves and so we worked for
for a year actually on that that
prototype which then turned into
something much bigger which is what we
first showed that the BG X's
Christmas Eve I got like a text and then
called saying like the the officers
starting to flood this this kind of
space that we had done up ourselves and
everything that was like you know kind
of quite personal to us I guess and was
pretty much kind of wiped out within a
few hours basically and we were back on
our feet in in a really in a really
crappy low-five way you know within a
couple of weeks actually we were we were
set up and and that was definitely like
indie development in like a microcosm
that it's like the highs of like you've
announced a game people others you know
you've been flooded you're destitute
everything's gone it's wiped out go
bankrupt so yeah it was a crazy couple
of months but and like they my faith
into the community like games the
community in general was completely
restored at that point you know and
times like this is at e3 we've had so
much positivity about the game you know
like you just never see that we're where
people really get behind something in
such a big way and that's massively
massively meaningful to us and really
feel fuels you
there is this thing that it's sat in
this infinite procedurally generated
universe but that's actually not why
we're making the game we're not making
some sort of tech demo or something like
that we had the idea of making a game
that felt true to the kind of sci-fi
books that we've grown up with the kind
of idea of that the fantasy of that and
we wanted to deliver on that and to do
that we had to create the universe feed
to explore because that's the feeling
that we wanted you to have for one of
the first times in games to actually
land on a planet and for nobody to know
what was on that planet not the creator
of the game and not anyone else because
no one else has ever been there before
give everyone a spaceship start them all
on a different planet give them a
working living breathing universe that
has planets with ecology that has space
stations in fleets of freighters and
military and police in different races
and all of them interacting and let
players loose and let them decide the
game that they want to play because
that's what's interesting to me I'm
really interested by things that are
less descriptive actually in less you
know hard-coded about what way you have
to play it and that don't start with the
tutorial and it just kind of let you in
and let you off to make your own fun
having said that it isn't just like some
sort of empty blank canvas you know
there is a lure to the universe and
their decisions that we make based on
that and it is it has a personality
it is generally a pretty dangerous place
to be
as it should be kind of for sci-fi it
isn't just some ambient utopia but you
are always in danger actually everyone
starts on it on a different planet but
ever starts and different plans on the
outside edge of the galaxy and they all
share that same galaxy and for most
people they will try and make the
journey to the center of the galaxy and
there's a reason why you would want to
do that but that is a journey that they
will undertake and to do that they will
need to upgrade the ship upgrade their
weapons upgrade their suit and they will
need to plan and they will need to
cooperate with other players to an
extent and and they will actually need
to be quite clever and there is a game
beyond that and you can continue to play
but for a lot of people that's the core
journey that they will be on they will
think I started out with the smallest
crappiest ship you could imagine and I
got to a point where I could get to the
center of the galaxy and see what was
there
and we want that to be significant